all right well so this is for anybody
watching on the livestream I'll explain
what this is this is a pretty typical
[Music]
design review of core language functions
form language inventing what we are
going to build in the future and you are
jumping into the middle of a fairly
elaborately abstract discussion of a
function called curry
ok so we've already talked a bunch about
curry but let's go ahead and start
looking at what we were going to look at
um okay so did you Jose did you did you
um why isn't why am I getting that okay
did did you make the changes that we
discussed yesterday or not and some of
them so I've changed a warden a bit of
the definition box and yes but there are
some comes there okay so how can I run
this somewhere the excrement has curry
yes okay most of them here today right
we've also got some notes from a while
ago yeah yes yes dude you made some
notes yesterday but fee what were you
looking at um
you haven't got AC or four there okay in
javanese toughness and fines okay was
that the one that was relevant that's
the one we we're writing yesterday okay
all right well so let's look at the case
that we still have to discuss so let's
let's go through the basics here so so
let's look at some use cases so curry of
F so what we've agreed curry of F of Y
of X is f of X Y so what's a real use
case for this it might be something like
curry of partition
of four comma of range of ten that right
yes another example I mean just
interested in is order for example to
reverse the argument ordering order so
how does that work is the Vickery of
order and then say 1 comma 2 and and in
this case yeah for example okay
so this implements the reverse order
why because order of 1 comma 2 wouldíve
1 well he had the arguments are being
passed to order yeah okay I understand
I see that's a little weird but so
effectively what in this case what it's
looking like as a composite function of
some kind where you know where it's
turning the sequence of sub values into
a composite function um okay so let's
take a look at the cases that we had not
done it how much even happens at the
various stages like if you just make
curry of politician of force does the
state I never dated able did it say that
giving the argument order sequence I see
that was wondering about function they
take mooted the number of arguments like
some its various ones or some Daddy Jake
does it evaluate if it has enough or
does it wait until it ASIS or number
then it calm so look that's to some as
an example so this would be an
interesting case so to make a summation
operator like that okay so that's just
going to sit there so let's take a look
into all of that applied to 1 over N
squared for example does the right thing
amazing that's kind of cool
um we don't want some special output
form for this courage thing here do we
perhaps we do it'll be nice to have even
an input form perhaps not well the other
possibility is during colonization it's
not obvious we want to give that to one
there we might want to leave it as curry
of some yeah I think we do I don't think
we want to give the to one because I
think this is kind of a nice case I mean
another question which we should raise
is whether curry is the right name
I mean curry is the technical name but
you know what this is really making is
some kind of composite operator of some
sort isn't that right I mean it's
basically taking um what is it doing
it's creating a function can you
describe it in some other way yeah I was
thinking of whether this should have
function some word or some sort of
transformation on the function and
there's also the question of whether
this is caring or uncaring because you
can't read it in both ways well by the
time we call the function uncarrier all
is lost
um the but let's say it was something
like big curvy out since of carry out
had it's almost a ton what do you mean
by curry out what what do you mean
something what's that
carry out this operation but not
carrying out ku being out it's not more
than a pun 10% more okay fine um okay
but so the notion of operator form let's
see you know what you're creating
it's kind of like well I wonder what um
just that the world at large whether
that has any synonyms for curry I mean
what I called this a thing a bit like
this in SMP but that was a very 38 years
ago or something was tearing TEI are
probably not very useful so in other
words that is the function in multiple I
mean that the concept there was this
concept of multiple tiers or flattened
out I mean this is some kind of um I
mean I don't really like this because
that would be more like a output form
but it's kind of like something that you
know ice because makes everything you
need argument well it undoes the you
know Asian gender I mean it's what it is
it's a wrapper here that is what what
this is if it's representing the
such-and-such form of F I mean this
wrapper around F is more like um you
know it's it's not yeah I see what
you're saying so f has been used in some
sense right in the sequence F prime F 2
prime what do you mean so I mean it's
like the unary form of ass well maybe
but what happens in so far we are mostly
examples just to argument whatever
there's four arguments does it fully
curly four times yes it's fully
clarified
I mean it's fully curried so well
actually that's not quite correct I mean
if you do something like this it'll do
no mandate of a P of C of T yeah right
comma for F comma for yeah I understand
it but if I do that then I can do
something like this then it pulled them
all together yes the brackets the
position of the brackets does not matter
it's kind of like a bracket flattening
but what would this be in the world of
combinators anybody know I mean this is
kind of a let's see I mean this is in um
I wonder whether there's any useful name
for it and um yeah I mean there's
there's words like partial application
hold also but this precisely these
weights until it has all arguments it
wants right so it doesn't do any partial
evaluation what about things like
chained because it's making hmm well
okay let's keep going with a semantic
sigh I'm not sure what this in terms of
let's talk some more about the count I'm
so sorry I see that you are adding eg at
the end
could this be carried instead of curry I
think it would be better to call it
curried um
I think it would be better I don't think
I stupid secure as hell
this operation is and is typically known
as covering right that's more or less
under yeah but but on the other hand the
operation here you know I think it's
reasonable to say Curry of F gives a
curried form I think that's the right
thing that's the active thing that we
want to give you me giving curry would
you eat or incur eat no no no no I'm not
I'm arguing against curried actually um
well okay
let's keep going with the semantics can
we please yeah so something that we
explored yesterday is the notation with
arrow so that there is a number goes to
our raw sorry number goes to list or
list goes to number or list goes to list
and I have been exploring that a bit and
it adds some flexibility but question
pointed out on our on our Twitter stream
somebody has pointed out that doesn't it
seem weird that curry that this curry
turns into that and in some sense it is
weird but it is the useful form so in
other words to get it the other way
round would be F of 2 1 right
no F of 1 2 1 2 X sorry but it is kind
of weird that the default case I mean
the default case is not useful you know
this case is much more useful in this
case so it might inform the name to
understand that it isn't quite the the
right term thing
yet the vast majority of the cases we
carry automatically are carrying the
second argument um yes right but I mean
again that might inform the name of the
thing but but any case um let's um yeah
like it's you might want to curry plot
saver suspect to the plot range but I
also want to supply options later can I
do this
not easily in this form we a way to do
options right so we can do that oh my
gosh what is that oh no that's not what
I want to do is it I want to do this of
that yeah so the way we were preparing
to do this is plot of list in this case
it would be 2 comma 1 and in the list we
put the options it's not implemented yet
but that's the way we were preparing or
perhaps I have implemented I don't
remember
can you try in after plot do comma least
2 comma 1 comma what range post-war I'm
sorry again yes yes there commander one
and in the list it not inside the list
we say plot range goes to all because
somehow this was saying put the argument
to document 1 and the options goes to
host I worked Michael does that satisfy
what you were saying not quite I would
like to supply the option later
depending on the function well then you
have to treat it as an argument you can
say carry plot comma 3 and curry is not
working with Varig things okay if that's
what they're asking okay so in other
words that was another case that we
discussed was the the case
Plus for example I'm making a curried
form of + where you can just keep going
and adding arguments but we don't see
way to do that all right so let's loop
back so whether if what were the further
questions that you had Jose and then
let's look at a few other things then
we'll come back to this yes so the thing
I do because I don't like the name okay
go ahead
yes so in the interest page there is a
new comment there which I'm calling to
see so I was exploring the possibility
that we discussed yesterday of having
list goes to list or permutation goes to
permutation right to allow the
possibility of permuting the arguments
of the curried function or permuting the
arguments of the f itself so there is
this mapping of the arguments of curry
f2 the map to the arguments of F and we
company levels so what we're saying is
in here we've got something there and
we've got the argument sequence here ABC
for example and there's the question of
whether in which order these things are
picked up and in what order they are
filled into the arguments of s correct
exactly the more general case we have
it's much more complicated because it's
we have things like this and we have to
say whether the whether you pick up you
know each thing has an address here
which you can in principle pick up
that's even more complicated
ok but so what did you conclude about
the permutation the permutation thing
well the conclusion is that we can have
a so there are two things here one is
whether the permutation on the left and
the permutation on the right belong to
or refer to the curried arguments and
the F arguments you can choose any order
because this can be read in both ways
but whatever we do should obey this
property I've written there which is
when we compose to curries there must be
some identity you see so
thank you so we may will have to make
sure that there is this sort of identity
now I'm not sure whether to read it in
the first way I wrote I wrote it or in
the second where hood yeah I understand
but do you think it's a good idea to get
both permutations or do you think that
it's sufficient to give a destination
permutation number goes a number goes to
permutation is enough this would add
some flexibility in case you want to
interpret it as under muting these
arguments or permitting the other
arguments so number as in in this case
it will be for arrow and then how you
fill in from these things here into the
arguments of F is that correct
exactly because for example we need this
in this particular case what is a is a 1
1 in this case so I might be saying
something like 2 3 1 2 is that what I'd
be saying yes so I haven't implemented
this double list notation but yes it
could be 4 goes to 1 1 2 for example and
then it's going to return F of a a ok
but wait a minute but that's a different
way of doing it because in other words
if a is B 2 or 1 2 in the current
implementation is to do we have a good
idea well this is something useful also
to not have to worry about where I'm put
into brackets but notice that there's a
very large play if you were to say a B
the sequence is 1 what it's worth I mean
then that becomes you can you can move
in that sequence of any length like slot
slot right so that's the analog of doing
something like this yes but here we have
an additional issue which is that our
semantics is going to try to evaluate
head arguments first
and then if that doesn't do anything it
will evaluate with the two parts of
brackets and if that doesn't do anything
we've tried to evaluate with three pairs
of brackets so because we'll have this
pattern that takes an arbitrary number
of brackets the only way of implementing
these recursively is by by flattening
brackets one of the time which is how
this is implemented right so by the way
relating to this as a discussion we
started Michael I don't know about this
nested function pattern business of
being able to write a pattern that will
effectively match that nested sequence
whatever that nested sequence is called
it is very related to this whole
currying thing I mean you know it almost
might be except for the fact that I
don't think that's a very nice word
either
you know um what is the right I mean
what is this really doing it is it is
accumulating arguments in some way this
curry thing it's accumulating arguments
by function application it's kind of
like like that's a horrible word but
it's like this thing is somehow
applicable to arguments as in in the
same sense that you might say apply what
did we end up doing with construct did
we finish that yet it's designed but not
implemented yet we should get that
implemented yes because yes okay oh did
we end up pulling it off what did we end
up calling it no no no but at some point
we called it yeah I just yeah
somebody is asking whether uncurl would
be there as well as curry yeah well
that's another interesting possibility
to take I mean how would you take this
and turn it into what do you turn that
into I mean you could try to turn that
into this I don't think anybody
particularly cares about that that's not
an operation that that we have found
very useful over the last thirty years
or something um anybody Siebel I mean
that the main point of this curry form
is because in endless situations in
which you are doing you know something
like you know something like that you
want to be able to quickly I mean you
know we can clearly make any function we
want here um you know whatever it is but
the question is what how to write how I
mean what we're really talking about is
simplified forms of the function that we
would write you know any anything we can
do with curry we can do with pure
functions yes am i correct yes so it is
merely a shorthand for a family of pure
functions so the question is what some
let's see I mean that the issue that we
have here don't really don't know where
I was saving this word under curry um
will have multiple pair of brackets with
curry imitating doesn't with function
could be rather complicated because it
would be nested functions which which
thing
I mean having curry imitating one peer
function is easy but but having what we
do is curry with multiple arguments
imitated by peer functions it's doable
but but I think it would require
multiple nested functions
oh yeah the mess which is what how we
have a function to do it exactly right
but the question is you know in some
sense what are we doing what is the
thing that we are achieving with curry
we are making this thing F somehow it's
not the right term I mean applicable is
not the right term what is that object
there what would you call what would you
put what name would you apply give to
this to mean that this is going to
construct you know it's going to be
waiting for I mean this thing like like
we have function right function is
something that waits for something to be
fed to it right that's a good example of
something which waits for you know
something to be fed so this is another
thing that in a sense in its partial
form here you know this thing here is
waiting for stuff to be fed to it yes
but I think the key point here is the
bracketing it's it's something like
converting a single pair of brackets
into multiple pair of brackets and that
operation another subset of partitioning
of the arguments makes me think of
compose so I don't think this is
composed what what are you saying no
it's not composing but it is alright
anyway what other questions were there
so there's this question about what to
do with variable argument sequences um
what other questions are there that are
still outstanding
well to me them the main fundamental
question for the point of your
implementation and this syntax is is the
notation of list to list to do we admit
list to list what are we happy with
number to list only it is enough where
the right hand side
says how to take the sequence of one two
three four arguments in these brackets
and stick them into the arguments of the
function exactly yes so a four means
wait until you have four no matter in
which bracketing form are they are and
then there is a list of numbers which
are basically like like this lots of
function and they can be repeated so it
could be 4 goes to 1 1 3 yeah mmm what
on earth can we call this I mean it's
something about application function
application isn't it mm-hmm
yes okay here's a there's a really weird
one partial construct I mean it's very
long word which is kind of painful but
the idea is if construct makes this so
what does constructor of f of X what
does this do f of X Y yeah our idea was
that that was the return returning f of
XY f of XY as we host the f of X of Y as
opposed to returning this yes yeah which
one that it would return the first one
this one here yeah I see so in other
words it's effectively turning a
sequence of arguments into a head and
arguments and so how do you make this
one how do you make this that would be a
folding construct that will be for what
you're saying though so if we say fold
of hash one of hash to would you can
just compost right now how compute just
come out compose yes and now that would
be the least
least have likewise okay okay so having
that construct to do this entry okay so
this is in a sense a you know this is in
a sense a decompose I mean this is a
fold of this here is a compose this is
that is that how compose that is the
official way it works right hey no
composes is composition that's a
different thing
it nests its permit did we is compose
what we deprecated in favor of
composition yes so right now the syntax
becomes duct yes to recover that we
would need construct of composition of F
X Y comma C to get exactly what you just
got okay but but then that would be I
don't understand here so so you're
saying no that that should work with
with look hash constructors effectively
hash one of hash two right
yes we're to look for two things right
so this will do that yes yes but I'm
saying that that's not the current
compose I understand
um
somebody's is talking about the aloe
interface from Haskell um I don't think
we have any
Haskell users on this call it could um
does anybody know how that works I don't
I mean the analogy the analog of that is
using hash one and hash two which allows
you to pipe arguments any way you want
in other words you can use composition
you know we can we can perfectly well
write functions with all kinds of funky
composition rules but we have two named
hash one and hash two I mean if we
wanted to we could be using Combinator's
but I think we're still going to have to
number you know we can make sort of a
Combinator thing that will you know so
it's an interesting point if we say um
how do you feed in arguments how do you
feed in a third argument now it's not
really a great term now I'm curious what
this Haskell arrow notation is because I
don't know um let's see arrow tutorial
from Haskell wiki let's see what does
that do arrow builds an arrow out of a
function okay
interesting simple arrow yeah well right
that is similar to our function exactly
that's our function yeah I think so oh
and we do have an arrow notation for our
function indeed we do right so we just
have to so in other words this is like X
function x squared and so on yeah which
is otherwise that but now what is this
and and how does that relate to I mean
that's another interesting possibility
that there's a special character form
this I think we don't understand this as
well as we should
well that function we can put in the
first element of curry so we come
through the arrow that you just wrote
has no sure I mean we can certainly say
curry of that I mean actually we can say
curry of X Y goes to you know y comma x
squared or something and then we can say
that becomes something that we can then
say of a B for example and that will
become like that it is kind of funky
that this is why default reversing the
argument order that does bother me
somewhat and it's kind of suggest that
it might be most assessing which in
which we want to just use curry off
something without saying
kamar something it's knit so no we don't
want to have to put a second argument
that the only point is that the name
curry may not be the right name given
that it does by default but the default
cases to do this this some slightly
weird thing where it is using where it
is making itself ready to take a first
dog
so to speak in other words if I say
Korea vas of why it's making itself
ready to take the X argument yes the
question is how how can you say that
would it be weird to call it
functionalize like we're kind of again
transforming it into a pure function to
some degree well are we operator thing
go ahead I was gonna say yeah I mean the
the thread we seem to come back to is
that the output of curry is most similar
to a pure function or at least the the
function head we have that's the closest
analogue we have in most cases I agree
so maybe along that line a little weird
if you see that on a piece of code
you're never gonna figure out what it
does
yeah so in other words it used to be
functional eyes of F of Y you're never
gonna figure that out I mean frankly
you're never gonna figure it out if it
says curry either we have said delayed
which does the setting at a delayed time
in some sense what about function
delayed or a flavor of it because in
some sense we delay a certain operation
yes well I mean alternatively it could
be something like argument I hate this
isn't quite right it's more like
argument delayed suppose it the
arguments apply delayed by that time
we're writing a whole si I mean or apply
delayed yeah
horrifying I mean apply something or
other could be usable um
hmm okay perhaps it's because I'm
already used to it but I still like
curry because we call this curry it's
such a such a short thing which is very
nice
well I agree um okay difficult problem
all right
okay so we've still got a name in
question here but let's keep going with
the rest of our discussion
okay can we can we move back to May we
were talking before about this
possibility of a patent construction
Michael do you have any comments on this
so you understand this pallet kind of it
would take us and it would work that I
can make it anywhere in in the head like
20 nested heads and anywhere I have
cabbage leaks well so what I'm saying is
this would say this would say nested
let's see this would say that's saying
nested what would be the right term for
it this would be like repeated but it
isn't repeated its nested right the
analog of repeated so in the case of
repeated what we're saying is F of
repeated of X you know goes to you know
Y or whatever it is right and what that
matches is that matches f of X X X X X X
X and if I were to say
yeah repeated ex blank repeated then I
would get that okay so what's the analog
so nested here would be but if you want
something more general if you don't want
the same no I understand but here you
can have it not be the same because if
you say F for repeated
oh I should say
under these repeaters black organics
repeated blank without a name that's
right yeah that that would be that will
match any of those patterns so here I
mean look really what this is is the
analog of it is a blank nest so to speak
in the same sense that blank sequence
that um X blank blank is blank sequence
right so if we have f of X blank blank
representing F of any sequence of
arguments that is blank sequence what we
want here so that is the current that
that is the same thing as f of X colon
blank sequence right so then the
question is what can we do that would
represent so what will be the
corresponding thing for a blank nest but
I'm not sure deciding if we do nest f
comma X comma five we don't get multiple
brackets I said fine so we could equally
well say here you're right it's not it's
a it's a multi composition right some
venue limit actually we probably need
the word that we are missing in
previously carry word the equivalent of
car I know I know that's why I'm
bringing this up um I mean because what
we would call it is a sub value but
that's what we would call the value
version of this um I mean the words we
have are apply construct sub value um
[Music]
right but what this is is a um we're
hearing some breathing here um okay so
that thing there what are we calling
this in the world of trees because that
the tree form right now the tree form of
this is something rather silly looking
right
don't even breaking it up um humph
okay listen let's try and loosen
ourselves up here with some hopefully
simpler discussions let's um this is
something that she has found and it said
the implementation here is a bit more
general than what we document so we are
asking for permission to yeah the number
of turing machines with this number of
colors is documented to be this well is
it just wrong Turing machine is able to
hundred more rules than and the
documented well as equals two cables to
I know the answer is 4096 so let's see
what that is so that's that's four to
the four would be that okay so you say
it's four times 4 to the four oh that's
really weird how can that be
I don't understand so what's going on
with it as I mention have one oh this is
more two-dimensional okay okay so what's
the issue so is this just an error the
implementation can handle the equivalent
of eight there instead of four no I
understand that but so the table said
four and so it seems like the bug right
yeah yes I just wanted to check that you
I have no no opinion about that I mean I
have to work it out if it's a bug it's a
bug um I mean do we need to it seems
like it's just a bug I would I would fix
it okay okay move on the brine sequence
review okay this is fairly trivial right
there is an issue that we have been
discussing with cheese
standard seems to be to use 0 to n minus
1 while probably in the buffer language
it's better to use 1 to n so what did
you know okay wait a second so you're
saying do is it is it in one of these is
it in there I don't know no you will
have it yet in this ok so I have to look
at this okay um okay let's look at the
example first yep the blind sequence of
0 1 comma 2 what is it giving here it's
giving a sequence where you're always
sliding down given the the symbol 0 1
you're making a sequence which has the
property that a length to block yeah but
you never repeat blank to block
what's that I mean that all possible
lengths to blocks like 0 0 1 1 and 0 1
are always there consecutively yes right
so so in this particular case if I take
that de bruyne sequence and I know now
I'm not ok and what I do there is I say
so there's an identity that you should
probably have here right the partition
of that comma 3 comma 1 should be the 8
sequences like that right why are there
seven six I'm confused
these no it's not all possible sequences
it's but go ahead but that was came out
from comma three here so you're saying
comma 2 comma 1 no but that gives the
repeat there but here it's it's severity
that says 0 0 and 0 1 so you slide on
the list by block of 2
so within it so that would be
partitioned comer to their right that's
correct then so I don't understand this
case then are you sure we are not this I
think this is sequences of order three
but perhaps there is cyclic
it's the cyclic condition no so this one
I like small son yes which three come
one and yes but then what's gonna happen
here then you're gonna get it's three
code by one comma brace 1 comma 1 brace
like this yeah yeah okay I'm especially
a little bit confused so this is
generating all possible you should by
the way give that example here yes is
generating all possible sequences all
eight sequences so that in some slightly
funky order what's that
so if you take the output to you took
the first three this is you as your zero
so this is the first event of partition
then you slide by one so the second
block is you as your one and you see the
second amount of partition so yeah then
you slide against zero one zero and no
okay I understand
so this seems fairly straightforward
this case seems well yes this this case
seems truly okay so what's the question
here so this is thing yeah so the
question is that if we if the input is
the bra in sequence to cover to do
interpret that first to 0 comma 1 or s 1
comma 2 I am and I think it should be 1
comma 2 well I don't think we
necessarily should support that there I
mean it's the same issue that we have at
two poles right I mean this is the same
kind of deal you know with tuples you
can give whatever you want there right
so I mean this is similar I wouldn't I
just wouldn't support this case
if we do support this case and I'm
skeptical it should work like digits and
should have a zeroes here in my opinion
well we have to brine graph already and
in decibel dub case so I think we should
we should you take that okay so if I if
I put in labels here that's not very
helpful let's see let me do let me do a
2 comma what would be the the right
thing - 2 comma 2 that's a very ugly de
Bruyne Goff so what I really want the
vertex labels is to apply a function is
to apply integer digits
comma 2 to that right this is a very
messed up to brine graph I mean that
usually you draw draw a de bruyne graph
I mean it has a certain symmetry which
is not well it is being captured in this
picture but it's in capturing rather
weird way but I think our sequences are
paths in this graph so prolly what this
means is that the one it does use 1 2 3
4
yeah which means that I don't understand
how that would work if you that means
that those things are not the integer
digits if I'd version of those isn't
going to be correct
this is what I'm saying oh I see what
you mean yeah what what is there a
vertex labeling function there isn't
there a son named birthday ok how do i
how do I get the integer digits thing of
those I just put a function in here I
don't know
of ash and you map this expression on
one two three four orange five [ __ ]
right there
that will certainly work
okay Oh
oh yeah a reason issue is at least it's
very flat actually I think all the
digits asked you pain post you can see
very helpful oh whatever
okay so fine I mean we can probably get
some that will probably work yeah there
we go
okay we didn't tell it the leading
digits there though I don't know how
many
so it's comma two there okay so those
are the digits of those numbers right
[Music]
you know this is consistent right to
generate the sequence with zero through
whatever is consistent with what's
happening here isn't it because this
here is the labeling of nodes
whereas this here is the contents of
those nodes if I'm not mistaken Isis
right it's the same thing that you'll be
doing if you say I mean if I say range
of whatever and then I would say integer
digits to get yeah I think it's
consistent so I would say that the
correct thing to do is to have it go
yeah it's to be something where if you
wanted to get the numbers of you would
say from digits comma 3d of those of the
sliding window on that list right okay
okay so I think that's consistent um and
here yeah that's fine okay what else we
need to figure out what the point
sequences I was a bit concerned with a
usable of the world alphabet here rather
than list of elements or such a list of
yes we should not say after that return
to the brine sequence
of the elements in right that's what it
is it's of the elements in list islands
in lists and it's basically taken K at a
time isn't it taken in at a time I'm not
mistaken
okay and I think that would be better if
you're really going to have K there I
guess you can do that um okay I can see
I'm right to the point
but that we gotta say on there and in
the second line on the list
c-dawg duking to n - K - 1
yes we tend to do it or end up with four
point sequence of the elements 0 through
K minus 1 turn to the point sequence of
the characters and stretch it maybe we
should say based on me of the elements
it's ok ok ok ok
the shift register sequence fairy
sequence is not spelled correctly and
will clearly not work there right what
is the relationship between the fairy
sequence and the blind sequence it was
mainly to add it sequence and there's a
generation of sequence of number diction
but do you know whether the fairy
sequence was related I don't see I'm
pretty sure that's not
then I don't is it really relevant to
talk about ferry sequence it'll cause
shift register sequence is related to
the Debye sequence right yes yes in fact
they're very closely related and I would
even put shift register sequence before
two poles because I think it's it's
really closely related and I would drop
ferry sequence cuz I don't think it's
very I don't know a relation um what
about what about rotate left is that
related or partition for that matter or
- sure yes okay all right let's keep
going here um so there was a suggestion
of reversal by so we have added recently
reverse sort and because people
typically understand better the use of
the F function installed by rather than
they or they function in sort we have
got a couple of of suggestions that we
had reversed sort by you know if we only
could follow that currying problem then
these functions all become well maybe
not I mean yeah it all becomes more a
little bit more straightforward because
this becomes I suited saying yeah okay
that doesn't solve that problem I guess
I'm okay with this I mean you know looks
sort and sort by are two things that are
kind of on an equal level in terms of
utility what is the sort by yes so we
have discussed this idea so the main
point here is that we have a function
that takes an f function and another
function that takes an ordinary function
but we don't have a function that takes
both so the ideas we discussed is to
have served by taking both with this
notation F ROP that's going to be very
powerful so we're working on that now
I'm a bit concerned with the fact that
these seams
second option so that notation of having
a rule at the very end could be
problematic if we add options or if the
functionaries so I was wondering well
there's mental active notation now sort
by the right takes um what does it
exactly mean why why did a one-way rule
well it means first take the F of the
elements in list and then sort them with
the order in function P and how many
arguments yeah what why not why not use
three or three argument forms so why not
have F and then the sort by so in other
words sort sort only has two arguments
as well right yep and it has an ordering
function in it so it's like the ordering
and then there's the ranking function
effectively and that's a possibility yes
so this one would have the ranking
function and then the ordering function
yes so perhaps you would I survive with
one of them only having to add anything
both they become equivalents of exchange
no that's strange I mean if we're gonna
do it then you know sort default to an
order and sort by defaults to a ranking
I see yeah because ultimately what's
gonna happen is and there's also
question what the priority order is of
using ranking versus using ordering so
presumably in sort by you use ranking
first and only to break ties and we
ranking do you use ordering am i right
well it's not so much breaking ties by
but for example if you have the example
I gave recently was we have a list of
vectors and you want to rank them by
norm but of course norms are numbers so
you need to use numerical order in the
third argument because otherwise we get
that's a different thing that's a
different thing so that's saying that's
a composed ordering and ranking that's
different from
no no it's it's this so so I mean the
breaking of ties would would be if we
have a list in the second argument and
in the third argument so that the first
function applies first and then it is a
tie we use the second one oh so you're
saying does that does that already work
so in a bi-state into one solid I in
survive but what about that case does
that use f1 function as the vs. ordering
conscience no these will be some sort of
tensor product or Cartesian product of
orderings will not support that yet but
in certain way we do support a list of F
functions okay oh yeah various types so
we probably should have a similar thing
for breaking ties with ordering and so
it shouldn't we we could we could I mean
that would be the symmetric thing to do
okay so this has nothing to do with
breaking ties so this has to do with but
I don't understand why so is it obvious
that the that'd be sorta for the
rankings is itself an ordering as
opposed to another ranking why isn't it
thought by by so to speak yes so the
ordinary function is a lot more powerful
because it takes two arguments so it
knows more than the ranking function
which takes only one argument so
basically the ranking function is just
being applied to the to the list at some
point about the ranking functions the
ranking function better return a real
number of some kind that isn't that
correct no no no sorry could return say
a string because it's its I see but then
there's a question of what is the
canonical ordering applied to the
ranking okay so in other words sort by
takes the list applies the ranking
function to every element and then has
to sort see but but you could imagine
look look you could imagine something
like this you could imagine a sort by of
a list of ran
complex numbers okay so let's say I say
random real you know okay so this is
going to give me whatever that I should
have given this sort by argument here so
let's imagine that I give that by well
abs is a bad example um what could I do
well I could say this thing here anyway
the ranking function is going to return
real numbers complex numbers but then on
to that ranking function and there is a
canonical ordering of complex numbers
which would lead to some ordering but
then what I want to do is overlay an ABS
ordering on those complex numbers
am I making sense yes that's it
indifferent thing so so the ordering
function is a way of specifying any
Janell or that it could be even a
partial order because Martin thinks into
reals means a total log and it's not
always the case we want that so so the
need of ordering functions is always
there for some cases that cannot be
mapped into reals yeah I understand I
understand that isn't always saying the
same thing I mean so we're saying in
sort by the ranking function takes the
elements in the list and applies a
ranking function to them and generate
something which is more canonically or
durable than the original element from
the list it's something or durable
that's ice anymore okay fair enough
well I mean but but look the elements
from the list always orderable to yes if
you don't like the cannot ordering
exactly right so what we're saying here
is the same thing is going to happen the
next time around the the ranking
function is applied to the list and it
generates a new list right I mean all
that's happening is internally right if
we say sort by list gamma wrath that's
equivalent to applying asked to list and
saying sort F of list
well you are contrary to our canto
return the original elements of the
lists I understand you're gonna return
the original elements but that's the the
sorting operation that you do is that
sorting operation exact exactly but you
see this the second sort has a p in the
second oh no I understand so what you're
saying is that this this is the ordering
criterion here but you could as well
instead of doing that you could in the
second thing you could do a sort by F
slash at and then the generic then the
identity function here that would be
equivalent if I'm not mistaken - what's
happening now with sort by yes but there
are some P or they're some orders which
are partial orders like like the
formalities things like that which are
not implementable BR so by I understand
I understand that all I'm saying is that
for convenience you're saying sort by
apply the function to determine the
ranking then those rankings have to
themselves be sorted somehow excited
excited could be okay so now we're
saying and what you're saying is that
the most general way to sort the
rankings is with an ordering function
it's with the two argument ordering
function okay and what I'm saying is yes
that was why the original sort function
had a two argument ordering function but
we found that sort by is often more
useful to have a one argument ranking
function so I'm asking the question why
do you think that the two argument
ordering function is the thing to give a
privileged position to in the thing that
happens in the ordering of in the
sorting of rankings so to speak it's
just generality it's just that it's the
most general case I can easily prevent
an order function from an F well it's
very difficult to in general not
possible to commit an F that keeps low
so what you're saying is so let me argue
this another way
okay so what you're saying is
this is the fallback position so what's
happening is that this F is just a sort
of a cheap way you know in principle you
can do everything just with this case
right yes yes but we would have to
compose the P and some sort of order
that comes from F right but so what
you're doing here is the presence of an
ass's our convenience but you're saying
you can fall through to what you can do
with generality with the P here yes I'm
saying that right now we don't have an
easy way to do well I understand well is
it something so in practice what would
this actually be this would be some kind
of lexicographic order and things like
that yeah we could have some sort of F
function that extracts strings and then
we want to solve them in Russian so we
would write F comma alphabetic order of
Russian so you're saying so the typical
case is that you are imagining ah does
that does that work - just a Russian I
think it's Korea bow like that right
yeah it is that's to be the case or
numerical order because we have exact
numbers and we want to sort by numerical
order that seems fairly sensible to me
III buy this anybody object to this no
let's do it I don't believe in this I
don't think we should do this I think I
should just be a third argument okay
that's good to me and just in one sort
with three or just something I don't
think we should bother with the sort of
three you've given an argument why
that's unnecessary just sort by right
you can sort by is the less general
function than sort I don't know if you
look yeah
um okay so this and the order to find by
applying after them so then then the
third case would be sought by though
we've called it P in the other case
right users what do we call it in the
case of sort um
[Music]
the ordering function uses the ordering
function P to order the results from
applying F to each element of list but
right yep exactly okay um all right
let's let's leave that for right now
future eyes but I think that makes
suspense Souter eyes that okay all right
great
okay let's um let's go to your last
thing here with the sequence replace
this you what is this yes versus list
from the second argument of sequence
replaced yes so then so this a new
function have to replace sequences and
we are using the notation list goes to
sequence so you see there 1 comma 2 is
replaced by a yeah so the point is that
so we are though it'll drift which is
standing in for a sequence exactly like
we have done for sequence cases sequence
position sequencer wouldn't that's what
whether it does not work in the external
okay but but I mean this case here if
what you did instead of that was um
replace sort of this whole well no you
did this wouldn't that work no it
wouldn't work this would work yes yes
what does patent sequence the parent
sequence will just represent yeah that's
fine so that will be so in a more
general case you could do something like
pattern sequence of X blank X blank
which would mean any subsequence of
repeated elements right so what's the
problem with this the naked speaker
doesn't work who cares what happens if
you had string replace and the first
argument had a head that was not less to
say L string replace what's I'm sorry
sequence replace sequence replace the IP
and this thing here go ahead so does it
work with non list head that should do I
mean that should match so you would want
F of pattern sequence of X X well the
question is does this work that's a good
question and I think it does so right
now we are always requesting lists in
both cases principle we could do matched
heads but if F was effectively you know
that that is an effectively a flattened
Abel a flat F of some in some sense this
is pretending F is flat and the other
one is pretending list is flat
I see and yes so the question between in
this language whether we also need an F
head on the right hand side of the room
that's the one identity question right -
in other words does that and if you have
an ass head on the right hand side does
it strip it but it's not going to strip
a list on the right hand side is it
right now we don't know I don't think we
should if you want a little tip so don't
okay so so you're su it the issue is if
you wanted to splice it in okay so
here's a bad case right so let's say I
do sequence replace of one two three
four and then I say 2 3 goes to 1 1 1
right ok ok that's going to insert 1 1 1
in the list which is really kind of ugly
because it's not what you want most of
the time you really actually want to
splice my mum 1 into the list yes but
that isn't gonna be easily fixed yes but
it was a different interpretation right
because now if we want to replace 2 3 by
by 4 we would have to say list for right
I mean if I wanted to create a sequence
I would use will delayed and sequence oh
I hate sequence I mean it just blows up
everywhere you know that's really the
fact you have to use rule - right it's
fairly horrifying why using rule the
light on all these places the idea just
is no it is Memphis it is not sir as
soon as you do that case which is a
horrific case no it doesn't work also
with rule it would be necessary if a was
in the left hand side so rule is also
sequence called
a rule in sequence hold so I can say 1 2
goes to sequence so I can do a splicing
like that kind of grotesque though I
hate encouraging people who use sequence
I mean the whole point of having these
functions like sequence replaces to make
it unnecessary to use the naked sequence
yes indeed so the main issue is that
right now we are using lists to
represent sequences on the left hand
sides but not in the right hand sides
and we wonder whether it should be on
both sides
um sorry further again yesterday issue
discussed here is that right now we are
using lists to represent sequences on
the left hand sides but not in the
references and we should do it in modes
right so there's a question whether it
auto splices from the right hand side
which would force you if you wanted to
have a single element it would force you
to say 1 2 goes to list a for example
yes right exactly so if the user writes
something on the right-hand side which
is not at least Google's same well over
correctly we might splice it in I see
okay I mean what are some analogous
functions I mean we have sequence align
don't we which is a sequence alignment
which has some similar issues I think so
what does that do um perhaps sequester
cases the closer fair enough so what
does it do when it has so that's an
example where it is not Auto splicing
here yes because this is extracting it's
not it's I mean the fact that it returns
a list is not the same list as the
original is the list of cases so it's a
bit different I said to say yeah so to
say right well what are some other
replace functions do they do
what does string replace do for itself I
mean string replace Auto splices but it
doesn't have any choice because just
characters right because string is
effectively a flat function what does
that do
it's the British impression which which
is basically taking objects and
replacing me using a permutation
interpretation right okay well I mean
look my tendency is to say that this
should splice that you should be
required to do this I mean the role of
this function is it is replacing the
sequences yeah what do you think okay
yeah well I mean it's not obvious the
syntax is right because I mean another
sorry um okay I mean in a sense a more
natural thing might be but then we're
into some totally weird and then why are
we even doing this I mean then then I
mean this is certainly related to things
like dominators
right so I mean a a Combinator I don't
even know you know I mean the typical
Combinator right the K Combinator
combinate or K of once the others at
work of Combinator K of X of Y is the
same thing as X right if I'm not
mistaken and then Combinator so so the
point of accommodator typically in the
way that combinations work they are sort
of Auto currying I mean they're always
curried they only live in a currying way
of doing things I think that one is some
what is it it's it's some X of Z of Y of
C right so those are typical good I
there is a Wikipedia page for Carine
using precisely that's what so I wonder
whether we can learn some terminology
yeah for what for Korean yeah let's see
what it does so a cooking process of the
same name see curry some great
validation of function takes multiple
arguments into an evaluation and into
evaluating a sequence of functions yeah
well that's the other way around
right this is this would mean that what
we're doing is uncaring right that takes
multiple arguments right that that would
be saying that the curried form of you
know this would be that would be
something which would say something like
this that that goes to f of X civil of Z
right well we can't read it in both ways
because Curry of F can be read as
transforming the function f that takes
several arguments into a function carry
of f that takes brackets I switch a sign
that makes some sense right so the curry
of F is a multi AAG okay so f is a very
args function let's say is a multi
argument function Korea vas is a nested
Lee applicable function
well so let's try that again I mean so
good same with the better handle what
perhaps perhaps award he has multi multi
arguments versus multi applicable I see
so that's multi argument so it converts
from a multi argument to a multi
applicable function what's a reasonable
concept what it does okay I like that
but now so now the question is what
should it be called um we can be
incredibly obscure here let's see what
is it talking about here so yeah I mean
these are the standard kinds of um I
mean Co Board isms and things these are
the standard really it was introduced by
Frager I'm mostly knew about it's used
by Shawn Fink oh um D functionalisation
earth is that I see
so if that was what that was called then
functionalize would be the corresponding
name here wouldn't it I don't know
whether it would be but you're right
this is a wrapper for the head partition
if I could spell right so I mean it does
kind of suggest with this what on earth
would if you read this thing how would
you know what it meant
how do you read this and have because no
this is okay so the other possibility is
curried of F but it's not really helping
anything
hurry about yeah to transpose for
example action okay now the next issue
is why Korea flips its arguments in that
weird way Yeah right even though it's
the more useful form hard to justify
that because it's the the naked name is
just going to be um what about having
forcing people to write something in
second argument like a two wave rule
which is nice to say freak one and two
well so what you're saying is Korean I
don't know but it seems very rich
forcing forcing a trivial statement
seems very strong well I agree but the
difficulty is that this film seems wrong
I mean in other words the fact that this
will wind up in the wrong
seems wrong we can still do this and
candle you force only to use the two
argument form if you want to switch no I
understand that but this the third case
seems wrong supposed answer I suppose
that's precisely this case by default
I understand but transposed everybody
thinks transpose interchange is
something whereas with curry but but the
the just pure curry can do in quotes the
right thing the X comma Y and if you
wanted to switch then you have to give a
second guard well I know what the
default case we believe is is I mean so
if you give this but this has been based
on the function that we often curry this
has not been proved on 200 randomly
selected functions why don't we
introduce to so like we do with look to
and we have a curry something which does
this super frequent case and then curry
is a strict not possible curry to or
reverse curry curry reverse reverse
curry sounds like it's gonna be uncaring
I see but we don't have a none curry
form right because because what we have
to go from so in your version of this
see in your version of this currying
this too many people currying that would
give this not really we should carry the
function because the function may
evaluate so we kind of trust that the
function is controls no fair enough fair
enough
okay so fine okay but but well
the proposal this case here does not
interchange things which might be
considered unfortunate or might not be
considered unfortunate so in other words
in order to interchange things you would
explicitly have to say curry of s21
right right who couldn't meet like curry
F comma reverse it's interpreted that or
something that I'm just trying to be I
mean I still think curry reversed curry
lost order it is lost it's just a second
right well we could also say last for
functions that that take more arguments
for example transpose by default
transpose is the first two level even if
the array is very deep well okay so
curry last is a possible thing to mean
if we say curry lost that's not going to
work
look we could take our last of F X Y Z
yeah I don't think that's coming what
would it do yes yeah you're right
because it needs to know how many
arguments are before no one would is the
last
well perhaps we need curry too and it
means carry the second one scary second
yeah other really so many convincing
examples of this well nearly
I know 90% of all fre all the functions
we have carried is for a second but then
we ended this I feel like this exactly
is the substance a little bit circular
it's the subset that is covered with
respect to the second not really I mean
there are functions like part for
example whenever we're able to have a
current version of part right and if we
did we would carry this it would always
curly respect to the first why I mean
look in the case of a part okay so that
would be curry part for you know and
then that's an operator to be applied to
one two three you know five six or
whatever I just wish this word was more
readable I mean this is just so obscure
the input I mean unless you know in part
of this part of this is because if you
anyway give to four in the beginning why
do you have to play it as an argument
basically in in the curry of part four
if basically what you want to prefer
prepare is a sink that takes always the
first element of something then I feel
like part and four come on equally i
aside and not before comes one later
I agree I agree no no do Hacha for right
that will make you exactly what you need
then that's not what I mean
like it could very that their argument
that's already given the four is not
applied as an argument to the curry but
it is an argument of curry it says no I
know I know I know I know that's what I
had a while back and which just doesn't
make a lot of sense right as soon as you
look it's like having construct
okay so construct F ABC okay let's
imagine that one of those was missing
but it is the place where you insert
something in right so you could imagine
something like this where one of those
things was you know insert here yeah
making sense
yeah and that that would then become a
function
I mean that's a little bit of a
different thing because that's not the
multi-step currying business because you
could imagine something where you have a
construct mm-hmm so this is a form of
slaughter that doesn't need the function
wrapping around I suppose I mean there
is a version of this this would be a
construct block okay so I've got a
concept here I mean construct um I'm
gonna say construct function but it's
hard to read but let's say construct or
let's say um and then one could imagine
something like this this is a little
weird but one could imagine something
like this actually what the heck is the
point of this this is so that is merely
equivalent to I mean it's just silly to
coolant to f of a hash see ampersand so
now think it helps you at all it's just
a way to provide you know this becomes a
placeholder that shows you where to
stick something which is given here
all right let's see um so we've got a
couple of things here we've got this
curry second here which is potentially
useful we've got the original curry
which is essentially a flattening head I
mean in the original curry form if we
indeed make curry of s okay what are
some terms that we have that this would
be the head but this is something were
it's sort of an auto flattening head of
some kind
it's called curry yes or the current
head encouraged function yeah yeah
that's the curried function that applies
to x and y and produces the ordinary
function all right look my provisional
conclusion is that curry with this
turning into this and curry second
turning into this make sense and they
would take a number of arguments and for
curry seconds the number of arguments
has to be always two or more I guess so
I mean there's a question of whether
curry
that's comma two could default to be
curry averse comma 2 comma 1 very much
because we now say 3 what do we do yeah
doesn't make any sense I agree it has to
default to be the right way around okay
well I think this is the best but I'm
still not super happy with the word
curry but we can think about it some
more but let's let's go ahead and
implement this if we can so we're ready
to implement here yeah and let's look a
squeak as Christopher or somebody else
what this Haskell arrow thing is see if
we can learn something from it it may
turn out to be just a call on to our
function slots business um okay
all right well if anybody survived on
this live stream um I hope you found
this interesting it's a bit abstract
today um and yeah well come back another
time for a come review of design of
something completely different
perhaps all right see y'all soon